how much have you used tick-tock i guess
you use tick-tock more i mean i don't
when i when i say i'm on tick-tock i'm
not really like religiously on tick-tock
i just go into it every now and then
when i'm like there's nothing to see on
twitter but again it's like i haven't
used it enough that i see a variance of
all sorts of content i'm still at that
early stage where i see 49 out of 50
girls dancing yeah same way which is why
like i found myself watching more
youtube shorts because it seems most of
them are just recycled tick tocks anyway
yeah but
i i already have a youtube
profile and so a lot of the content is
already tailored to the stuff i've
watched on youtube and every time i log
into tiktok i don't see a lot of these
tick tock trends that have just been
become viral yeah you know even though
everyone seems to be talking about them
i'm just like well it's not appearing on
my timeline i don't know i don't know
what i take two shot trends very lightly
now have you seen some of the latest
ones like what like have you seen i do
like a few more about like this episode
like i remember a month ago i just
wanted to die inside because there was
this trend called like devious oh yeah
yeah or something which was just okay
devious licks are just people who just
went to like bathrooms
um and kids would start stealing like
the soap dispensers okay and then it
started off as that and then you know
how tick-tock is you know how the
internet is it starts escalating to the
point where people are just full-on like
you know they they're stealing like
sinks sinks
road signs and then there's like people
that stole whole vending machines
okay hold on how the [ __ ] do you steal a
vending machine i totally do that i
don't know you have to pray some of the
logistical abilities here yeah but it's
stealing
but at the same time you're just like
committing like almost grand grand theft
auto like and just putting out on the
internet
it was a trend that was widely condemned
and every youtuber under the sun oh yeah
you had a video condemning it i mean
it's easy it's a slam dunk when you're a
youtuber to be like hey guys stealing
bad
applause now please
i just can't get over that someone had
the balls to steal a vending machine i
don't even think reaper men are allowed
to do that all right man all this all
the treats will still get stuck anyways
yeah
i'm just more surprised that just people
were just stealing and then filming
themselves stealing yeah yeah well
people aren't so smart when clout when
cloud is offered yeah
yeah
when cloud is on the table anything you
know yeah function like a normal human
being or prison time yeah did you hear
about uh couch guy
or the couch guy no that was very funny
that was the latest trend as well what's
that i heard about i'm scared to ask um
so it was this girl who basically
surprisingly visited
her boyfriend in college right
and she walks and she walks in and
the guy her boyfriend is sitting on a
couch and he doesn't seem as excited as
you know maybe one would expect okay so
he acts a little bit awkward you know
and uh he then he eventually gets up and
hugs her right okay and twit and i was
going to say twitter tick tock takes
this like 30 second clip and was like
he's cheating on her
he literally like went like full uh
netflix documentary true crime yeah yeah
like he had to take care of you
by frame and like it was insane and it
was just like the worst part of the
internet just like so was he cheating on
her no no no they said no but they were
like they were like yo they were like
they were like yo calm the [ __ ] down
yeah big big fact
like like maybe he just wasn't excited
no no exactly brother there could there
could be so many ways you you could spin
this narrative right and there were like
literally people
just full-on projecting their narrative
towards this 30-second clip like i saw
this one tiktok that was just like uh
the girl released a statement that was
like that and she said you know this is
there's nothing more to this clip i'm
friends with all the girls you don't
need to worry about it i know the girls
yeah and this one woman uh posted a tick
tock being like
girl you don't need to worry
you don't have friends because i've seen
friends like them they are not your
friends
friends should be excited when their
friend steps into the room we've all
been in that position i'm just like
british if there's anything i know right
if there's anything worse than an
internet detective it's an internet
therapist
like like those are the ones where it's
like let me tell you why your life sucks
you say it's great yeah but it doesn't
let me tell you why it's like dude leave
me alone yeah yeah
jesus yeah it was just like like like
you there is no way you can break down
this much of a narrative through a
30-second interaction
yeah yeah i mean there's this it's it's
the thing about the internet right where
there's like some zodiac killer [ __ ] it
is it literally was
i was have they found him yeah they
found him recently
they found him he died and he left a
review for the movie did he left a
review for the zodiac is it is this
confirmed yeah how did they find him uh
there was i think
he died in like 2017 yeah
quite a while with how they found him
there was some scars i can't remember
exactly it doesn't really matter they
found him basically and then he left her
i just i i don't care how they found him
i wanted to know what he thought about
the movie
and he left a review on the imdb page
did he say it was good or i think he
didn't like it
i don't know that's just kind of funny
even though it's fun
[Music]
reviews his own movie i don't know why i
just [ __ ] weird
jesus christ anyway before we move on i
forgot to give you something last week
joey
me and sid got a bunch of omiyage for
everyone and
i said i said
i was gonna give this to you on the
podcast but uh oh [ __ ] here's uh here's
some tea i got some tea i did get joey
omiyagi i gave it to you last week off
camera yeah yeah yeah i'm not trying to
shill my friendship
well no that's perfect because you gave
me cookies yeah yeah yeah you eat so
it's like the perfect conversations
biscuits
no because i would you know what i've
realized after like buying omiyage for
people from like
from like english omiyage oh very cute
very cute it's a tea set nice thanks man
yeah no worries no because what i've
realized is that we're friends guys
analyze that clip analyze it analyze
that frame by frame well joe joe he
hesitated
he wasn't as excited as i thought he was
jerry wasn't that excited
does that mean there's there's some [ __ ]
going on there's some [ __ ] going on he's
definitely cheating
you you you tell a lie
oh you joke but i mean uh there is some
kind of truth in that in some aspects i
have seen people on reddit or on the
comments right super analyzing our
reactions to things like what i can't
remember there's been there's been a lot
though yeah they'll be like oh wow
connor seems really sad today yeah but
red it's like a [ __ ] free-for-all
when it comes to that kind of stuff
yeah they just
people perceive us sometimes yeah and
sometimes in a good way sometimes in a
bad way yeah because doesn't everyone
always say that you always look angry or
like tired yeah everyone's like oh kind
of i am tired a lot of the time yeah
that's because i have to i wake up early
but um i you know yeah some people like
he's angry i'm like no i'm just that's
just how i am my sister's resting face
yeah you'll know if i'm angry um
well will you maybe you're there i don't
know i'll storm off yeah he just won't
be here
yeah no but like yeah reddit i've seen
some stuff on reddit where it's like wow
you got it ain't that deep bro like you
didn't have to go that deep you know
it's it's difficult because on one
aspect i understand that all they have
to go off of
ours is our episodes
and that's all they have to go off yes
yeah but i wouldn't by any stretch of
the imagination say that trash taste is
reflective of
well i guess it is reflective of who i
am but you miss a lot of nuance right
like it's very easy to generalize
um who we are and it also is a show
right so we are we do you know that i
won't lie there's times where i'm like
i'm gonna keep this argument going
because it's great content yeah
a lot of the times i wouldn't some of
the arguments i get into with conor or
joey are not arguments i'd get into with
a random stranger right because because
i i i would just i don't even know i do
feel strongly about a lot of things as
you guys know very well
i also in general life just don't give a
[ __ ]
to argue yeah i i like arguing in this
space with the boys i don't i didn't
even give a [ __ ] on the show
just joey just like [ __ ] trash tastes
like literally
what
sometimes i do like to be able to
explore other sides of opinions yeah
yeah
but it also is like if it is a you know
sometimes there are controversial
opinions yeah but they are opinions and
then they are sometimes commonly held
opinions
and it's one of those things where i
would like to play devil's advocate in
some situations uh without having to be
like connor is that kind of person he's
yeah just to get the conversation right
yeah you know we've always said we don't
have to be a circle jerk no no and i
always want to be able to talk about
topics and say things yeah it just makes
more for a more interesting show yeah
yeah and you know if anything i i would
wish that sometimes you would like not
assume
exactly
our thoughts and opinions on things
based off of